the only credit I will give myself is
when other people break and give up and
stop I just don't do whatever you need
to do to remind yourself only execution
matters so my entire youth I feared pain
I moved away from pain if something was
emotionally or physically difficult I
avoided it
what's that believe nation it's evan my
one word is believe and i believe in you
and i want to see that great thing that
you have inside of you come out so you
can help change the world so to help you
on your journey today we're gonna learn
from entrepreneur Tom wheeler and my
take on his top ten rules for success
rule number one is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which one you guys
like the best and as always guys as
you're watching if you hear something
that really resonates with you please
leave it down the comments below and put
quotes around it so other people can be
inspired and when you write it down it's
much more likely to stick with yourself
as well enjoy what does that believe
nation and Evan Carmichael Evan I have
been using your content for years to
help me prepare for my episodes of
impact theory so I am incredibly honored
that you're doing one of these top ten
rules for success on me and believe
nation I hope that you guys get a ton of
value out of this and that it helps you
build the mindset that you're going to
need in order to actually execute on
your dreams and until then my friends be
legendary
take care
when you launch quests there were 1600
other protein bar companies that
launched in 2010 flavors or companies or
companies yeah what gave you the
audacious mindset to think that you
could compete against all those plus the
10 20 years of other nutrition companies
out there and beat them yeah it's I'm
having any experience in this yeah I'm
gonna give you a phrase that I play in
my own head that I know and I say out
loud 50% of people love and 50% of
people hate me for it but it's true so
hey here we go I have the arrogance of
belief I believe in myself no I believe
in one thing about me I am NOT the
smartest guy I got a 990 on my SATs I
took it twice that's my combined score
that's bad for both of us
I was joking people a monkey smearing
feces on the test could score higher
than I did like it's literally terrible
yeah but I always believed that I could
do whatever I set my mind to right so
that's the only the only credit I will
give myself is when other people break
and give up and stop I just don't write
and it comes down to the story you tell
yourself about yourself and that's the
story I tell myself it was just this
last weekend I was at an entrepreneurial
organization and they brought a
world-class mountain biker in and said
hey anybody that wants to go for a ride
with her go and I thought okay you know
I'll go and and cuz she's saying we can
do a beginner course whatever I thought
was perfect now jump on the bike and go
I've never been on a mountain bike
before ever in my life I've been on a
bike of any kind probably in 15 years
that was probably stupid and we're in
God's Sun Valley Idaho so it's not
exactly flatland and we go mountain
biking and I'm dying I'm just done it's
it like 6,000 feet first of all so I can
match my breath and I keep stopping and
everyone's like yeah you know you took
hey man like go ahead and turn back it's
all good it's all good and I'm like I
don't think you know the story I tell
myself like there's no universe in which
I stop so I keep going finally they've
done the loop right some people have
turned back whatever they
done the loop and now they're coming
back and they're passing me I'm still
headed out and they're like you need to
turn around and I'm like I'm so sorry
but I'm not gonna turn around and they
said okay but then we're no longer
responsible for you and I was like okay
I like it is what it is man I appreciate
that no worries I'm a big boy
like go and I just kept going and I must
have come in an hour and twenty minutes
or something after everybody else but I
finished and that meant so much to me I
was like I'm gonna ignore the fact I got
my ass handed to me and I came in dead
last yeah yeah but I'm gonna be proud
that I didn't quit interesting did you
say arrogance of belief is that you say
arrogance of believed now if you don't
know this quote live by it one can have
no smaller or greater mastery the
mastery over oneself that's da Vinci da
Vinci did amazing things with his life I
wanted to do equally amazing things with
mine and if that's the game that we're
playing if I can construct my belief
system if I can choose at any moment to
believe something that's more empowering
than I was believing the moment before
and that that will actually find its way
into my actions allow me to do things
that I couldn't do the moment before
then it's like that moment in the matrix
where neo realizes he knows kung-fu and
that's like as funny as that is that's
how I think about life to me the very
fundamental purpose of life is to find
out how many skills I can acquire that
have utility and then put that utility
to the test in service of something
greater than myself
how many skills can i acquire that have
utility put that utility to the test in
service of something greater than myself
that is for me the purpose of life now I
don't actually want to know kung-fu
that is not the mission that I'm here to
live but I knew that I had to identify
my mission so what was going to be my
mission mother Theresa is an amazing
quote nobody will act for the many but
people will act for the one and that
really struck me
because I realized they were right I was
looking at this global pandemic of ill
health and I wasn't moving into action
but thinking about my mom and my sister
or the uncle I had who ate himself to
death when I was 12 years old that made
me want to act can you describe what you
mean by going into the darkness I can
alright so going into the darkness I
think everybody is motivated by two
different things one you have the
beautiful things in your life the things
that are going well the things that
you're grateful for the things you're
moving towards instead of a way you have
a compelling vision of your future it's
something that you're very excited about
all of those things are the beautiful
things now the flip side of that
equation are the things that it's people
that doubt you its haters it's things
you're moving away from
it's fear-based things it's something
that you absolutely refuse to let happen
so one that is incredibly potent to me
are the people that want to see me fail
so it's very different than people who
just think you're going to fail I
actually don't have a lot of aggression
towards people like that but people that
want me to fail those people I have a
lot of aggression for and I find in very
acute moments the darkness serves you
better in very acute moments now the
light the things you're moving towards
the things that are beautiful the things
that you're grateful for all of that is
the only winning strategy
long term because the darkness becomes
corrosive you start to become bitter you
start to be angry you stop being
optimistic you stop seeing things in a
way that's empowering and positive and I
mean just thinking about the deep limbic
system when it gets inflamed you
perceive things as negative
I think negativity stops people from
making progress there's a whole host of
neurological reasons and the sort of
mindset reasons why I think that being
negative over the long run becomes very
very detrimental and hold you back but
from an acute standpoint they've done
Studies on this if you want someone to
be able to endure more pain the surest
way to get people to endure more pain is
to let them
get angry let them be aggressive and in
doing that people are able to withstand
in the clinical trials I'll say that's
probably more than this but in clinical
trials they're able to withstand 30%
more pain so just straight being able to
take more pain anger and aggression lets
you do 30% more so that's why I think in
acute ways and short-term bursts that
the darkness will serve you there's a
gap between who people are and what they
tell you they want to accomplish because
in the beginning I hired everyone
everyone right not because I'm super
smart and thought hey I should there was
no one else right like we had the
smallest handful of people ever and so I
started doing the interviewing as I was
doing it I start realizing God these
guys tell me they want to do something
amazing with their life and if you just
listen like wow yeah like I want to be
in your team dude you're gonna do
amazing stuff and then you realize I
can't execute on that dream so if I
can't think they don't have the mindset
yet like theirs you could do an entire
podcast series on how to get the mindset
but I'll just use Carol Dweck and her
amazing voting mindset as I'm sure such
a good book I see Simon's the neck up
there who is also very influential in us
and she says some people either believe
they're smart as they're ever gonna be
and that's that so they're gonna be ego
protective and they're gonna you know
try to thwart anything that makes them
feel like they're not the smartest
person or whatever and then there's
people with a growth mindset and they
realize I'm not the smartest person and
I'm certainly not as smart as I could be
yeah so even if I am the smartest person
I ever lived I could get a little bit
smarter and so when they're confronted
with contradictory information they
learn and they soak it up like as well
whereas other people are fixed mindset
right correct it's done like no this is
the way and I'm writing that's wrong yes
and I would say the world everyone's on
a spectrum right even I as much as I
believe in it and work my ass off to be
a growth mindset
I still have let's call it 10% where I
catch myself I'm like come on dude you
know better than that yeah but so people
that fall in less a sub 50% spectrum of
the growth mindset it's got to be 98%
and I remember this was a piece of
advice that my father-in-law gave me
that I promptly ignored
and we have since apologized to him and
very much adopted this mentality but he
said the most important thing in
business is to know more about the topic
than anybody else in the room and if you
don't see an echo of that in my
preparation for the interviews and I'm
not doing a good job of explaining it
that was something that when he said it
I am so sad to report that it did not
hit me but for whatever weird reason it
really stuck with me and it was one of
those things that I thought about and
thought about and thought about and then
it finally manifested itself and me
realizing that to get good at anything
whether that's business whether that's
interviewing it really is that level of
preparation it is about going above and
beyond to get good at something and I'm
thinking about this last night at the
event and there's always like a thousand
questions that I get asked about how you
build a business you know whatever your
dream is how do you go and actually
manifest it and the honest answer to
everything is get better get better and
I've had really talented artists begin
reaching out to me on Instagram because
obviously that's a huge focus for us in
the next phase is going to be getting
writers getting artists bringing them
together creating amazing comic books in
Phase one and they'll have like a really
small following and they'll say you know
like what what am I doing wrong what's
the secret and the truth is even though
they're really good they've got to get a
lot better and when you can be
world-class but admit that you're not
yet undeniable cuz there's unfortunately
a lot of people that are world-class
like think about it you make a deal at
Olympics your whole life you've been
busting your ass you finally make it
you're one of the best in your country
truly a world-class player but you come
in seventh eighth it's you haven't
gotten to the point where you're so good
that you can't be ignored and that like
in today's world where social media
rules everything and anyone can get on
there create noise you've got to find a
way to cut through the clutter and a way
to cut through the clutter one of
there's more and I will recommend
and perennial seller by our boy Ryan
holiday really interesting book really
excited I think we've booked him for
like November that'll be a lot of fun
but is in his book he talks about
several of the other things you're gonna
do but I'll say that the most important
one is to get so good that you you
cannot be ignored cannot be ignored so
if you're being ignored by the way the
world has told you that you've not yet
gotten to where you want to get to so
everybody knows my obsession with Disney
read the Disney biography in times of
trouble Disney always came back round to
make the product better make the product
better only execution matters burn that
into your nervous system
get a tattoo do whatever you need to do
to remind yourself only execution
matters thinking about it feeling good
about it those are awesome but if you
have a vision of something you're trying
to do become whatever and you don't
execute against it and I don't need you
to want to build a big business if you
tell me you want to be the greatest
parent of all time then I'm gonna ask
you what are you doing to execute on
that goal what are you doing how do you
define it
what are your deliverables what are the
metrics by which you're judging yourself
and by the way if you don't want a grand
goal you don't need one but then say
what I'm trying to do is get centered
I'm trying to experience happiness even
that you can begin to look at ways that
you can improve that your talent and
intelligence are not fixed they're
malleable so you suck at skateboarding
because you're afraid of pain so the
only thing you need to know right now
the point is not to avoid the pain and
you need to stop asking yourself what's
the least you can do to get good and you
need to start asking yourself what's the
most you can bear to become great once
you understand the whole point is to let
the suffering and the pain harden you
into becoming the version of yourself
that you need to become in order to
execute at the highest level to be
world-class at anything and stop
avoiding it stop being afraid of it and
start understanding for what it really
is which is the thing that shapes you so
my entire youth I feared pain I moved
away from pain if something was
emotionally or physically difficult I
avoided it and I remember being in the
gym one day and going will you stop
asking like what's the least you need to
do to consider it a full week workout
because it was like could I stop now
could I stop now could I stop now and I
was like do you want the muscles or do
you want to like put on a show that you
showed up like you showed up right like
cuz the muscles demand what the muscles
demand like you have to break them down
you have to push you have to do more
like so it is purely a question of how
much you're willing to bear because
there's never gonna be enough you could
have always done more everybody lean in
nice and close self-compassion it's
probably the most important thing that
you can do for yourself is when you [ __ ]
up
you need to forgive yourself okay so
that's really really important so and
I'll walk you through an example about
whatever twenty minutes ago I get really
frustrated when people are trying to
tell me something but they're whispering
definitely red lines me in a way that I
can't even begin to tell you and so it
just happened while I'm here live on
camera and I hold myself to a standard
of catching my emotions before they rise
up now this has happened twice today the
first time it happened I caught myself
yay the second time it happened I was
like for real we're doing this again and
I got very frustrated so I was very
disappointed in myself for that I need
to be compassionate towards myself
forgive myself for that get better use
it as practice and remember that life is
in performance it really is about
practice so once you can meet yourself
with compassion then you can begin to
let go of whatever it is that's really
with your mindset you can get back on
track
you can refocus and don't wait til
Monday and that's a mistake that
everybody makes so if you fall off the
wagon like five thought the wagon at
9:58 at 9:59 and back on the wagon so
I'm not waiting even for a 10 o'clock
like you literally do it right there at
that moment make it a part of your
identity that you're the type of person
that does that so that is really really
critical right now between me and the
person I want to be between you and the
person you want to be there is a gap of
skillset and that's it but once you know
your mission and once you believe that
you can accomplish anything you set your
mind to then you can do the
extraordinary now for me getting out of
that space of being lost of not knowing
what I wanted to do with my life
it all came down to needing to earn
credibility with myself in very small
incremental ways this is me sixty pounds
ago and I knew if I was going to
accomplish anything in my life I was
going to have to get control of my mind
now ironically there's two ways to get
control of your mind way number one is
directly going to the mind which can be
very scary can be very daunting very
ethereal it's ephemeral it's hard to
grab on to it's hard to touch but way
number two is through the body and so I
decided that my kungfu
was going to be to get very good at
developing my body and in that process I
was going to learn about nutrition which
would allow me to help my mom and my
sister in that process I was going to
earn credibility with myself and earning
credibility with yourself is so
important do it in micro ways for me
just showing up to the gym every day was
a micro victory I said I was gonna do it
and I did it now you have to understand
I hate working out so for all of you
crazy people that get an endorphin rush
from running I hate you all running for
me is like being stuffed into a meat
grinder there is absolutely nothing
pleasurable about it whatsoever
so whatever neurological thing you guys
get that you've been blessed with I have
not been blessed with that so for me
showing up in the gym sucks eating a
bowl of ice cream is awesome and so
getting to getting to a better place for
me was a totally different journey thank
you
and what that was was just showing up
every day and putting in the work it was
reading about human metabolism and
understanding how what I eat impacts my
body it was earning a little bit of
discipline every day knowing that well I
did it yesterday I can do it again today
it was not eating something that I
wanted to eat and most importantly and
if you're taking notes write this down
it was about changing my identity
because at the end of the day identity
and values drive behavior for each
identity and values drive behavior so if
you want to make a change you have to
change your vision of who you are you
have to begin telling yourself a
different narrative and the narrative
you tell yourself about yourself is
everything and if you tell yourself that
you're a scared under educated kid from
Tacoma whose family has never
accomplished anything let me tell you
what you will become a scared under
educated kid from Tacoma who never
accomplishes anything because that's
what you believe you tell yourself that
story enough and it will become real but
on the flip side you could tell yourself
a story of you're a learner you learn
faster than most people you're willing
to put in more work than most people
you're willing to read more books than
most people you're willing to spend an
inhuman amount of time every day
improving your mind simply by getting
new ideas into the system and that you
will admit that you're wrong faster than
anybody else that you won't let your ego
get in the way and you tell yourself
that story over and over and over so
when somebody comes and tells you how
stupid you are that you're just a dumb
kid from Tacoma you go you're right
that's amazing thank you for pointing
out that flaw because now that I'm aware
of it I can improve it because I'm the
learner and once I switched my narrative
to being the learner it didn't matter
where I started it only mattered where I
was trying to go and as long as I had
that clarity then I could execute
because I believed I could do anything I
set my mind to without limitation and
then the last one which is maybe a
little bit controversial because I use
this word to get people's attention it's
all your fault
that what I mean by that is you always
can control the outcome of anything so
the example I give to people do it don't
have time to I give you a horse okay so
the example I give to people and this is
something that I do in the interview a
lot so that people understand how we
think a quest and if they think it's
crazy I tell them if you think this
story is crazy you should turn and run
in the opposite direction you will hate
it here but if in hearing it like oh my
god I want to be around people who think
like that then you'll get us after
hearing this story goes like this my
wife is British that's actually true
let's say that she was at home visiting
her family in London she's in the bed
that she grew up in the doors are locked
the alarms on her mom's there she's safe
and sound right at that moment a
meteorite comes screaming through the
atmosphere crashes into her bedroom and
kills her whose fault is that now every
time I asked that question once people
stopped trying to guess at what they
think I'm gonna say and they just give
their answer they say it's nobody's
fault divine providence fate force
majeure dumb blind luck however you want
to sum it up but that and my answer is
no it's entirely my fault and the reason
it's my fault is because I know that
there's a group right now the track what
are called near-earth objects that's
very true by the way they're trying to
find some way to knock them off course
so if it could be something truly
dangerous so whether it's a laser beam a
planted nuclear explosion whatever it is
something to bump it off course it
doesn't collide with earth I've never
sent them an email with encouraging
words I've never sent them a dime on my
money I've never called them up to give
them any ideas nothing and I know they
exist now I think that's smart because
the likelihood of my wife being killed
by a meteorite is very very low I'd be
much better off focusing on car safety
or something like that but I choose not
to contact these people I choose to
leave my wife at risk of being hit by a
meteorite sure so even though I would be
mortified and sad if it happened I would
never waste time saying that it wasn't
my fault because I could have done
something and I chose not to yeah that
to me is empowering that don't want
people feeling guilty about it you
shouldn't waste like I wrote an article
about this one time people like y'all
you're you're blaming the victim and all
that stuff and what I'm trying to say is
you don't have to allow yourself to be a
victim even if
been victimized right like you can
transcend that and you can look back and
go what could I have done differently oh
my gosh I could have done all these
things awesome
I'm now in control again yeah right cuz
being victimized is inevitable but being
a victim that's a choice right it's like
pain is inevitable sufferings a choice
yeah yeah so once I freed myself from
the belief that I couldn't break out of
certain things like everyone told me oh
dude your mom and your sister like
they've got to want it keep what kept
saying that they've gotta want it
they've got to want to change and I was
like I reject that because they're gonna
die like they clearly don't want it so
but I'm not willing to accept that I'm
gonna lose these people who I'm I love
so much I'm not willing to accept that
so I'm gonna acknowledge the human
condition which is that they eat for
pleasure and not for sustenance so I'm
gonna give him food that they can eat
for pleasure that's good for them yeah
my sister's lost 120 pounds so it works
right and my sister owns that like she
did excuse me she did the hard work like
she put the grinder
she should be super proud of herself but
at the end of the day the it was born of
me not accepting that she you know that
I had to wait for her to make that a
responsibility yeah exactly yeah so just
paint that - any area of your life
whether it's you want success it's not
happening as your bosses or whatever no
your boss may be it but you haven't
learned how to persuade to do what you
want
right right right which is how I think
which is why I say I want to be a Jedi
because I want to be able to persuade
people to do things so that I can move
the ball forward on the big goals that I
want to accomplish and yeah just own it
you can always change something
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Steven Odie
asked me to if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you would like me to
profile next check out the link in the
description and go and cast your vote
I'd also love to know what did you learn
from this video that had the biggest
impact on you what lesson you're going
to take and immediately apply it somehow
in your life or in your business leave
in the comments below I'm really curious
to find out I also want to give a quick
shout out to Jason from HarperCollins
Christian publishing Jason thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word and posting the link in
the review on your Linkedin I really
really appreciate the support Jason and
I'm so glad that you enjoyed the book
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
[Music]
maybe the most important reason each and
every one of you should start working
out and it has nothing to do with living
longer because we could get hit by a
meteorite who knows so I'm not even
worried about that but I am worried
about this when you watch your body
transform you get the loudest signal
from your subconscious that you can
change that you can change anything you
want that you can change your bicep your
tricep your quad whatever it is you want
something that you literally could not
do the day before you can do today and
your mind sees that that's true your
mind sees that something you couldn't
pick up yesterday you can pick up today
and it begins to ask itself
well if that's possible then what else
is possible it's important to me to have
the balls to look at the biggest
problems we face as a society and say
that's my problem to solve right obesity
metabolic disease the slide towards ill
health however you want to categorize it
that's my problem like I don't even wake
up thinking that's my business partners
problem that's my problem
I'm working with my business partners
because a very sharp guy yeah but at the
end of the day like I own that
responsibility and that's awesome to me
right like having that it isn't a weight
that drags me down it's like this goal
to chase that's so big that I'm just
stoked that there are people in the
world that are prepared to dream that
big like I'm inspired by that in others
and hopefully can inspire other people
with our dream but there is one truth so
you have to burn into your nervous
system I can't remember where I first
heard this but your network is your net
worth the people that you meet the
relationships that you cultivate they
are going to be that next phase in your
development they are going to be that
next relationship that next partnership
that next thing introduction that turns
into some
that allows you to scale and grow and
get beyond yourself because that is the
thing about scaling you will never scale
if it's just you you have no leverage so
you've got to meet other people that can
get the ball rolling that can introduce
you that can give you that key piece of
information that you need to really go
on and do something so get out there
meet people be yourself
let your freak flag fly introduce
yourself stance Superman awkwardly next
to somebody that you want to meet like I
did tonight and just say what's up
introduce yourself tell them what you're
up to and if you want to be interesting
be interested ask them find out what
they're about find out what makes them
tick
that's the secret that'll get them
rolling and then you can see if there's
a real connection and if there is from
that something can build so get out
there